we're doing good now three weeks
postpartum we're both like
getting it all figured out
tori roloff's responding to fan concerns
over her son josiah's appearance the
little people big world star shared this
sweet post celebrating three months
since she and her husband zach welcomed
their third child but some fans in the
comments had questions specifically
questions about josiah and why his
tongue sticks out everything's been
going really well but he's been great
and you know
i think pretty straightforward kids tori
addressed the fan concern by responding
in the comments explaining a larger
tongue is a characteristic of
ichondroplasia he will grow into it he's
pretty easy like he's definitely more
easy going ichondroplasia is the most
common form of short-lived dwarfism
which impairs bone and limb growth and
affects the spine and skull
it's the same condition josiah shares
with his dad and siblings five-year-old
jackson and two-year-old lila jackson's
very much loves being the older brother
lila follows him to the end of the earth
and then yeah we have josiah here
tori and zach welcome to josiah back in
april he's doing great yeah he um came
early three weeks early three weeks
early and the couple told e.t josiah's
big bro and big sis are taking a very
hands-on approach they both like they
try and pick them up they bring the
stinky like
why i was really concerned that he like
has his diaper changed yeah
i've been telling everyone this but like
they're very overzealous sometimes
though we have to like
slow down you know like
you can't pick him up you're only two
yeah you cannot change his diet don't
take his diaper off okay whatever you do
as for if we can expect any more kiddos
to join the rolloff clan we're still
probably done after this it's been
harder to say that though it's harder to
like we're done because he's been so
easy i'm like oh maybe we could do one
more but
[Music]
you